so we are the simons institute is a
collaborative research institute and we
run uh two programs every semester
typically and each of them has about 70
long-term visitors junior and senior to
berkeley and each including a boot camp
which is the one what we are starting to
today
and three workshops that bring even more
visitors and this semester the graph
limits and process on networks from
epidemics to misinformation is one of
those programs which is your program so
welcome to the boot camp of this program
and i want to thank the organizers
question board jennifer chase she's not
here yet nicole where's nicole
somewhere
she's uh disturbing us in amin it's very
who's very
well behaved and
um
thank you and he's here you know right
so for arranging an excellent set of
speakers for this week and in a minute
i'll actually hand over to christian to
speak about the details about the boot
camp
uh i just want to say more generally
from the perspective of a director what
are the goals of a boot camp
is um
essentially it's an icebreaker for the
program both from a scientific point of
view and a social point of view
hopefully we'll get everyone on the same
page
on what the spectrum of the program
themes are and
it will also be very good for us as an
archive for the state of the art in the
field uh at this point
and uh one year later after this program
there will be a reunion and
many things that get started in this
semester are actually going to take
effect
and be finished uh later but not while
you're here
and in the year when we have the reunion
it will be a chance to see what comes
out of the program
and
[Music]
another thing that i'd like to say is
soon you're going to get a lot of emails
from us if you haven't already to ask
you to update the research report um
sort of to talk about your research and
that's going to happen mostly i guess at
the end of the program but throughout
the program you'll get various emails
announcing social activities and things
to do in the area
um and all this you know answering our
emails and
and um crediting research done here to
the simon's institute is very important
for us for various reasons some obvious
like fundraising and and record-keeping
for through computer science at large
and uh i guess another thing to say is
that we're always looking for new
programs so if anybody here during the
semester comes up with an idea they
think will be wonderful to pursue for
whole term uh please let me know
uh some logistics as you know we're not
supposed to bring food or coffee in here
but there's plenty of food and coffee in
the breaks outside lunches you're on
your own
masks inside are not required but
strongly recommended
lockers are available on the ground
floor
uh there's wi-fi you know it's cal
visitor or eddie room if you have it
from your
um institution where you're coming from
and we're using a hybrid format so
there's both streaming and in person
a
in our videographers omid who's sitting
there in that little room
and uh meet far
and they will assist you if you have any
problems and and mike put mics on you
and so forth
so finally a big thanks to elizabeth
ewan our uh there she is elizabeth our
events coordinator for all her work on
the local arrangement for this week and
feel free to ask her anything that comes
up and i again i think i've met you in
the orientation but i want to say again
that i hope you have a fantastic
semester and take advantage of this very
unique time and opportunity
okay
thank you i will not spend too much time
to take it away from the first speaker
so uh i just wanted to welcome all of
you uh
i mean nicole jennifer and i are really
happy to how this has come together we
have a lot of nice speakers this week
we will cover
today's program is
sort of representative for
the whole week we'll have one talk on
graph limits
and sort of more general the area let's
call it graph limits graph modeling
random graphs things like that we have
one talk on epidemics which is our
second large community
and then we have one talk on economics
of networks
and that will weave through the week in
various formats um will
i don't know that i should go to the
program day by day but we will have
three lectures on graph limits we have
three lectures on
modeling random graphs and limits of
sparse graphs
we'll have four lectures on economics on
graph we have three lectures on
epidemics
and then we have
a few lectures on processes on graphs
which are not epidemics or economics
well they sort of could fit into both of
them by amin and giganei uh on
cascading processes on networks and um
percolation
models for epidemics things like that
and finally nicole will give us a talk
which i think nicely summarized how
these communities actually have a lot in
common without knowing it
she will talk about
segregation models but the interesting
things for us for tutorial is she will
use what's called the differential
equation method and that's actually very
similar to methods people use in
epidemics to understand
um how actually you have large
stochastic
epidemics which then behave
deterministically
and for cs it's the other way around we
try to understand some stochastic
process we come up with some artificial
epidemics and then show that this has a
law of large numbers which and actually
proves what we want in
computer science and nicole's talk will
be an example of that
um
with that i hand it to the today's uh
chair which is i mean
so he from now on i don't control
anything anymore so amin will control
everything okay
since i'm in control of let me just um
so first of all welcome
and
one thing that i want to add given that
we have a multidisciplinary
audience
the point of the boot camp is to give
you know sort of uh
everyone
you know sort of an understanding of the
language of the you know sort of people
that we have from mathematical
epidemiology from
economics operations research computer
science and
the discrete mathematics and probability
please
slow down the
speakers and if there's something that
you don't understand i have talked to
christian and i'm sure other speakers
will agree with me that we want to make
sure that we will have an interactive we
will have interactive talks so
um starting with christian i'm gonna you
know sort of uh slow him down if i feel
like he's going uh too quickly and uh
also with the rest of the speakers um
and uh with that i'll give it to
christian
my own microphone
um
so let's see where this guy works
um
our monitoring question is i said we
have online
people here are there people online
do we know that
are there people online
are there yes so how can they ask
questions
oh they i hear them in the ether okay
good
okay so i'm very happy to talk about
this this area which uh
we together where we would see with whom
we co-invented now almost 20 years ago
so let me just get into it okay
so
really if you
these will be the three questions and i
will try to answer them at various level
of depth so i will first have one slide
on each and so when we started looking
at graph limits
we were actually working on
some
i think routing on the internet or maybe
it was actually web spam so we tried to
understand how the worldwide web looks
and we were discussing this jennifer and
i were discussing with lazy luvas and we
were saying look we want to understand
what's natural because then you could
maybe decide what is web spam and what's
not webster and we feel it's a huge
network so you all know probably what if
you're a community you know what's the
limit of a large graph is and we want to
now understand how sort of smaller
graphs go towards large graphs because
then we can understand how the growing
internet may be growing naturally or
there is some web spammer who is sort of
artificially trying to get high paycheck
um
and then lazy said sorry such a theory
didn't exist and so that's how we
started discussing that
and i will um today discuss this
actually for
dense graphs because it turned out it
took us a long time to actually deal
with dense cars even though obviously in
the end you want to deal with sparse
graphs if you talk about the internet or
any networks i mean there are some maybe
dense networks if you have small
biological networks maybe they're dense
but in many cases the networks we have
are sparse right i don't i'm not friends
with the positive fraction of the people
on facebook
and
same for the web same for routing and so
on
good so
what are the motivating questions the
questions are you have two large graphs
on different number of notes
linkedin and
i don't know uh facebook okay are they
similar are they not what does that mean
and mathematically
once you ask this question you will
very much fast be led into the question
what is the limit of a sequence of large
graphs and finally
a related question is well how do we
model large graphs which was also
interesting to us okay and these three
turn out to be very related so let me go
a little bit more into it okay so
when should we consider two large graphs
well it turns out if you go a little
around you will get very fast
contradictory
requests from all your friends you talk
to the combinatorists or the social
scientists and they say
look i want to know how many triangles
are closed so how many friends if i have
two friends how many of those are
friends with each other which goes into
counting triangles or counting the open
triangles sort of open arcs
counting how many clicks are there or
five people where actually two of them
hate each other they never talk to each
other so complete graph is one less
missing and so on okay in the
combinatorist are very comfortable with
that that's extremely graph series i
count subgraphs so these two communities
get along okay
starting with eric
you have the statisticians who will say
no no no this is sort of nobody can
count graphs you should just sample from
a large graph and see what you see and
you want to see what the distribution of
the small graphs you see
your computer scientists will say all
very nice way too local you want global
properties what's min card max card
maybe you have generalizations of that
and finally your physicist will say no
no no no no this is still not good
enough you want to put an easing model
or some other statistical physics model
on it and i consider two graphs similar
if actually the physics on them is
similar okay so this is
number one
okay now it turns out
that all these notions for dense graphs
at least doesn't hold true for once they
get sparser it only holds partially true
but for dense graphs it turns out
they're all equivalent
this
this one it turns out to be actually the
most easy to prove um it's more or less
over observation by the iconis and
johnson there's much more in that paper
but this equivalence of the first one
came from the iconis and johnson the
year after we started that and we
actually were not really aware of that
part when we developed the theory
so because at microsoft there were
machine learners but no statisticians
i'm just joking
anyhow so
what is
what is the right limit is then the next
question
and
now if you have these notions you may
say well it's very similar it's some
vector in some
infinite dimensional space it's a
collection of subgraphs a
it's a collection of distributions
it's a collection of
various cuts or it's a collection of
front set energies
which is not very satisfying
and
so it turns out here comes the first
time graph on so let's pause the moment
what is the graph one so in this simple
setting a graph one just consists of
a function on the unit square
into zero one okay so think of it
as the generalization of a graph right
instead of a graph which has a vertex
set you now have
a set of real numbers and the adjacency
matrix would be vertex set times vertex
set here the analog will be real numbers
times real numbers
and it goes into 0 1 so it would be
weighted adjacency matrix so it's a
continuum analog of a graph
and it's a relative natural
limit object um
and uh
that was sort of
uh first
realized by luvas and sagetti and then
for one of these quantities and then in
a long paper so
bc lsv will always be
box chase lovers shows wester gumby
which was sort of the original group as
it started
i really still very fondly remember
working with vera shoes she's this
granddam of hungarian mathematics if you
have ever met her she
suggests you can't but like
okay
so finally how would we want to model
large graphs
well
eric ryan is a contouring gnp everybody
probably knows i will recall what it is
slide generalization are stochastic
block models used a lot in social
science where you have different groups
which connect with different
probabilities and the question is what
is the right generalization and again
let me just give the answer right in the
beginning
so there's a theorem by aldus hoover
which i will walk you through
which says that essentially all natural
dense random graph models can be
generated by a graphite
okay now either hoover
the name graphon
i think we invented with lazy i still
remember a conference room at microsoft
in 2008 or 2009 where we came up with
the word so aldus and hoover certainly
didn't know the word graphon they didn't
even know the
the theory of graph limit was totally
not discusser so this connection to the
crf graph limit was not known but
actually this theorem was already around
not be known to us when we develop this
theory
and so now i will formulate that a
little bit more general so a graph one
is still a function of two variables
okay it's symmetric
so
if you exchange the two variables it's
the same
and it lives on some probability space
which you should think as a space of
features
and then if you have a space of features
you can say everybody in your potential
social networks has some features
and if amin and i have certain features
we have a height i'm originally german
he's iranian so there's some discrete
features we have some intelligence we
have some taste and now as a function of
these two features it's more or less
likely that we connect and that is what
these models do so they also seem quite
natural if you formulate them but really
iris hoover says that this all there is
if you ask some very natural conditions
so
to summarize sort of what we will do
we will
have
large graphs with the vertex set and jc
matrix
we'll have graph fonts which consist of
some probability space which is your
feature space
and a symmetric measure function
and graph limits it turns out
lead from here to here
and non-parametric random graph models
lead back
so
i think i should so if you remember
nothing this is sort of what you should
remember there all these different
notions of graph being similar that turn
out to be equivalent
once you have sort of similarity you
discuss what a limit is the limit
can be expressed in terms of a graph on
and if you have a graphene you can use
it to generate large random graphs
so far
is other questions this is roughly clear
i mean am i too fast am i too slow
okay
good
um
now so how would we model large graphs
so probably most of you know
what gnp is but let me just recall it so
it's a simple most graph you could
imagine you have n vertices
and then you have n choose two possible
edges
and iid each of them you choose this
probability p okay so they're zeros and
ones but it's sort of stochastically
extremely homogeneous
and
because it's a homogeneous it's not
really used much
but what is used a lot actually is the
stochastic block model so here you just
postulate you have
um
k groups okay so you have
in this room i don't know since i was
describing i mean and me that way say
you have groups of different
nationalities and now the iranians and
the germans happen to sort of like each
other a lot which has a history at
microsoft and then that of other nations
they may not like this others that much
and you have sort of iranians iraqis may
not be that likely to be connected and
or indians and persians indians and
pakistani so it sort of depends and then
again the exceptions right but when you
do it stochastically you come up with
this matrix of probabilities that your
different groups will be friends
and now you have these groups of people
which in the simplest case we just say
are chosen at random
and then you just connect people which
com belong to community x and y with
probability b x y where b is this matrix
okay
that model is used all over okay if
people want to understand
in the background at linkedin when
people try to model things and model it
like that okay
um
so
it has all its problem if you have to
have sort of
ten thousand
different groups it starts to be
questionable whether you're over
parametricizing and whether maybe what's
called a non-parametric model might be
better
which is the so-called inhomogeneous
random graph so you have this graphon
okay so some symmetric function over
your feature space
then you have again a vertex set in
and now rather than a group membership
you choose a feature in your feature
space
and so
the random
germ and iranian my random height my
random interest in sport versus
classical music and then for all i
smaller than j you connect i to j
independently with this probability if i
is connected to jj is connected to i so
that's why i'm writing this
and in our simple setting graphs have no
loops i'm not sort of friends with
myself
um or everybody's friends with myself
and in which case we don't need to put
it so anyhow graphs are graphs without
loops
so the way you've written the stochastic
block model there have to be as many
iranians as germans okay so this is the
simplification for this tutorial
in general you could instead of the
uniform distribution you can choose some
distribution
which is
in this model automatically because i
have put a mu
okay so you're totally right you will
not in general want the uniform
distribution you could always subdivide
your groups to make them roughly equal
but i just didn't want to have the
hostic blog of np and another vector of
probabilities and everything gets more
complicated in notation you don't learn
anything new at least mathematically
if there are more iranians and germs
so um
so how would we
right so now the question is how general
is it okay is that natural or not
and so now i'm going to
wait a step back okay
so i looked as a following i look just
it's a very simple setting i have a
sequence of random variables okay you
could think of some
medical data or we just observe in the
real world some sequence of
of random variables in this simple case
they're in zero one
and we call them exchangeable if you
think of this for example as discrete
time
if time doesn't really matter if you
could reorder time and get the same
distribution
so we have this sequence of random
variables
such that the distribution
of
any subset of n is the same if i permute
the labels okay so the distribution of
x1 x2 x3 is the same as that one of x3
x2 x1
okay
so now my phone is speaking well we'll
eventually
okay so
so let me give you an example because
that may sound very weird to you okay so
let's do something which is called the
puglia which someone who has heard of
the polio
okay so the polio iron is a very nice
probabilistic model which is used to
model a lot of things actually in
computer science um
and it's a very simple model okay so you
have this urn
and in the urn there are balls
okay
you shake the urn you grab into the urn
you pull out a ball
in this example happens to be red
and if it's wet
you grab another red ball and throw it
back into the line and if it's green you
throw it green and then you repeat okay
so you have this you start with r and g
red and green balls and you do this
process
okay
and now let's look at that a little bit
okay so what is the probability of the
seeing the sequence r r g g
well the first time you have r plus g
balls in your bin the probability that
it's red is r
now after that you have r plus one red
ones in so you have this number of balls
and this is the probability of seeing
red
now you have one red more so you have
this probability divided by the next
normalization and now you sort of the
probability of getting a green one
they're still just g green ones in it so
it's g over the normalization and x
times g plus one
okay so what happens if we want to if we
look at the probability of getting a
different order
okay
well the first one is the same red over
red plus green
and you might sort of here you might
think look if i have done rrr now i'm
sort of much more likely to see reds
because i have more reds in there right
so maybe this sort of would have a
tendency to actually eventually be sort
of concentrated more and maybe this is
sort of
looks more mixed so maybe it has a
different probability
but actually it doesn't it has exactly
the same okay and why is that well when
you draw your first red ball you have
red over your no so first of all the
normalization just goes up by one each
step okay no matter what you find
now when you do the first fret you get r
when you do the second red you get r
plus one when you do the third red you
get r plus two it doesn't matter
where the position of these guys is so
you always get
this expression
okay for the polio iron you can
calculate everything exactly which we
won't do here
which i did in my graduate class
but
there is a very nice theorem which tells
you what happens to this
sequence and the theorem says
essentially
this behaves as if you were drawing
independent coins
now
it's not really independent coins you
see this is not just always the same
probability so what am i talking about
well i'm talking about this here i'm
buying a guy called definitely it's
quite old and it holds in a much more
general settings i can sit in in any
nice probability space okay
so assume you have an exchangeable
sequence
it means that it's environ under
if you take a final subsequence you will
shuffle it has the same probability
so
then it says the following there exists
some probability distribution on zero
one
such that
you can actually obtain your sequence by
first doing the following you can first
draw a probability p from this
distribution okay so this is a
continuous distribution
which gives you this value p
and then
uh
after having chosen that you just can
choose this iid
uniformly at random at this probability
p
and if you calculate that for the polio
urn
you can actually do that explicitly you
will find that this distribution is just
a better distribution if you don't know
what the better distribution is don't
worry you can just calculate it and i
can write down what the beta
distribution is
okay
we know much more which i sort of just
mentioned namely that actually if you
look at your sequence
if you condition on the empirical
averages conversion to something
that something will be obviously p
and
conditioned on that you get this
independence again so another way of
formulating this theorem would be saying
given exchangeable sequence
it's the same thing as an independent
sequence once you condition on this
event in the sigma algebra at infinity
which is this convergent empirical
average
okay
so this is a super nice theorem it holds
very general in general just
this will be here sort of it was on zero
one in general it will be if you have
discrete random variable with k values
it will be distribution over the simplex
in general it will be a probability
distribution on probability
distributions and you can make sense of
it
if your space is
the random nice to be obtained by
a process like
i mean
are you saying there's some sort of
convergence between if i do the polyarm
thing and this coin flipping thing or
so what i'm saying is if you imagine
doing this for your earnestly forever
okay
you might want to calculate six right
because you may want to calculate well
what is eventually the average of
of whether green or something like that
right so what i'm saying just
so as an algorithm you could either do
your polio something run it forever
or you could do a different eye person
you could draw you flip it you find the
p according this better distribution
then you choose a p
and now you choose your sequence
independently
so to some extent
if you had seen the whole sequence
then effectively you sort of for this
polio and will have decided what
eventually the strength of red and green
is and once it's decided what the
strength of red and green is eventually
you actually can now just act as if it
were independent
and that is used a lot when people
analyze things like preferential
attachment or things like that where
it's more complicated than that but
there
you there would be no way you could
calculate anything in these models if it
were not for this beautiful series
yeah
to clarify you're saying that the
whole sequence that you would get from
doing a foia or earned experiment is
the same distribution as the whole
sequence that you get during this iiv
stuff yes
right so i'm saying do the polio earn
step by step forever you get an infinite
sequence we have a probability
distribution of infinite sequences so it
has
some probability of seeing a particular
sequence where
if we use this success okay let's not
worry about the mass there's some
probability of seeing a particular
service
and if you instead if you want to
calculate that probability you could
instead just do this better distribution
which is
okay let me just describe to you in
words it's just choosing
uniform random variables i think r plus
g plus one
which you put in your unit interval and
then you look where you have the first r
and where is the rsg and the better
distribution is the position of this
point in the middle
which is another way of thinking it of
predefining a strength of red versus
green
um
and
so so you have this setting
for each for an arbitrary sequence of an
arbitrary lines
the probability of
this being generated by the point on is
equal to the probability that the
sequence generated by that always yes
so in the end it's the cm on finite
sequences right so you take an outer
length for your own sequence five
okay so back to this example
so instead of calculating this you could
have done something different you could
have looked at the better distribution
drawn a p at random and then done
five independent coin flips the
probability p you choose y plus
probability one minus p choose 3
obviously for 5 of them this is simpler
than coming up with this better
distribution but once i send 5 to very
large this better distribution it's a
much easier way and it's sort of morally
you sort of essentially you sort of but
in this process as you put green green
and red the strength of red will vary
right but eventually they'll settle to a
certain ratio of red and green which is
not equal to the original one it will
set it to something
but once this something has settled this
is sort of this p
and then you put sort of but it turns
out that actually the finite things are
just exactly the same
to some probability to some constant
which is a random variable
okay and the distribution of this random
variable is in this case given by a
better distribution yes
do you have another question yeah
do
this does this theorem tell us how to
find this probability or is just an
existence
this is just mexicans proof so for the
polio earth but in many cases
actually we can then calculate it so
you're right it to be really useful it
would be nice to know what this
probability is it's the only thing i
know it said
i actually don't know okay so if you
have some medical experiment or
something like that you will have
actually empirically
find out what this probability p is
and then but for that reason a lot of
processes the fact of people say okay
it's probably exchangeable
so if i condition on this sequence
running forever which is probably
doesn't
um
then there must be this probability
distance so now i can just act as if i'm
there dealing with independent events
and i can do my sort of all my
statistics for the medical events i want
to do
acting as if it were independent means
over is not really independent
okay so in practice you can either
you're sort of like in the pool you're
on and you have to be clever to find the
distribution at the end or you have to
empirically sort of find this p and then
maybe if you would you run your
experiment again you would get a
different p because it's a random
distribution on this piece
yes
you want the general case okay so i have
x1 up to x and living in some polish
space you want to know this kind of
stuff i want to know the national theme
this question you soon should
immediately notation is not clark here
just shout and don't raise your hand
just interrupt
the ep is bernoulli p
which is just a fancy notion for a coin
so it's a coin flip with probability
okay so this just said
x1 up to x and each of them can
independently be chosen to be
one with probability p and zero is
probability 1 1 minus
this
any other notation i didn't explain
ok
good
so now we come sort of to the islands
and for that you have the notion of so
we had so far exchanging the sequences
now we have exchanged the random graphs
so in words an exchangeable graph is
some infinite graph
such that
if you look at any finite
subset of vertices and you exchange
the labels of this vertices okay so
instead of the naming the first three
vertices are mean nicole and christian
you name them christian recall and amin
and then the distribution of your whole
infinite graph
should be the same
if you change the labels okay so this
means you will have graphs which maybe
the graph itself is not invalid under
the labeling in that case it would be
because we're all friends but maybe we
haven't sort of
maybe amin and nicole are stronger
friends because nicole is a really good
person cook and i mean likes it so so
it's not really symmetric but if you
sort of exchange the labels if you look
at an unlabeled graph it the
distribution should be independent okay
so in another realization
i mean would get a different feature
nicole would get a different feature i
would get a different feature and in
distribution
the relationship between the three of us
should not depend on our labels
okay so if you so
that is called
exchangeable
okay
and now
i can give you a formal definition if
you're a mathematician
okay so if you have an infinite random
graph it has an infinite adjacency
matrix so it's a matrix of zero and once
where you have a one if there's an edge
and the zero if there isn't
okay so that is your random array
and it's called exchangeable
if for all n
the distribution of your array where you
relabel the first n vertices in some way
is the same as original distribution i
don't say that for each realization of
your graph this is the same as this i
say they have the same probability
okay
and if you're really a mathematician you
will sort of say well
you could use different
labels here and here it doesn't make
much sense for a graph because the
vertex has one label but
so there are different notions of
exchange record jointly and separately
exchangeable but
forget about that my definition here is
this one and this is the one we're using
okay so now
is the question what is the analog of
the infinity okay and now since i gave
you a random graph you might say oh it's
very simple it will be just you have
some distribution on p and then you draw
g and p and you're done
okay and you might suspect that if you
have this exchangeability among all
vertices this thing should look pretty
homogeneous
but actually that's not the case
and
so
so but me
okay so here comes the cr
okay so aldous hoover says
if we have this exchanger array okay
or
formulate differently we have this
infinite random graph which is invalid
under the labeling
i put the diagonal equals zero because
we don't have self loops
okay then the theorem says the following
there exists a function of three
variables so he had it in this form okay
he didn't have the word graph on it
didn't even know that something like
that exists
there's a function of three variables w
alpha x and y
from zero one to the power three into
zero one
such that we can generate this array by
doing the following
first you choose sum alpha
so uniformly at random so alpha is
pi over 5.
okay and now depending on that alpha now
you have a function of two variables
and now you use this function of two
variables the way we did before so you
choose x one up to x
two and so on an infinite sequence
uniformly at random in zero one
and then you choose
the entries of your matrix adjust
independently with probability
p equals w alpha of this x y should be
up of x i and x j
with that probability you put an edge so
this probability is different for every
edge
because typically this w of x i x j is
different for every edge
but it has sort of this global
invariance by the fact that
well
if i if i choose these in a different
order right they have the same
distribution
and from that this graph will inherit
this relabeling in variance
and the theorem said this is the only
way you can get that
in modern theory in modern phrasing
which is not theirs
which
the iconus and johnson pointed out
this can be rephrased as if gn is a
finite subgraph of an exchangeable
infinite random graph
then the distribution can just be
generated by a random graph on w right
and the randomness is mediated through
this alpha
do you mean an induced subgraph there
what's the difference between the two
so and you so a sub graph is if i have a
large graph
so this graph
has
this graph has a subgraph
here okay so this is
you choose a subset of vertices it's a
subset of addresses it's a subgroup
an induced subgraph means once you
commit on the vertices
you must have all the edges in
so this is not an induced subgraph here
it happens to be an infused subgraph
here
but
um
if i had a sort of different large graph
there are no sorry
i take an infinite triangle lattice okay
it has no induced subgraph which is an
open triangle
but it does have many subgraphs which i
would try
okay so
and
and he's right gn should actually be
uh the graph you see when you just look
on the n vertices which means
so i have a couple of questions
um the first one being why did you
choose x and y from
zero from the interval zero one instead
of integers
so i could think of a different
formulation which makes some boy but
we're talking about chosen from
numbers from one to one and
so this still makes sense
it would still make sense if you so iris
and hoover just formulated it like that
okay
now um
we formulated graphs differently we said
there should be some feature space
and x and y should be from that feature
space
and you can choose um so your shifter
space has to be rich enough so for
example you can't say the feature space
is just the color red green
but you could choose the feature space
to be the actual numbers if you put the
right probability measure
because i mean it's sort of right i can
real numbers i can write down as a
sequence of zero and ones and then you
can sort of map that in some way so you
can find some discrete space which would
be
essentially isomorphic to
the interval zero one
and
um
and the other way around for example if
this w
will only depend on
if i had a w which would just look like
this
zero one
which looks like that and there's some
values here
okay then you see that w only depends on
whether i align the first interval or
the second
and therefore this would be equivalent
to just choosing your feature space to
be
the numbers better green and give
probability one half to red red and
green green and you can probably want
sir to red green i mean
so maybe i should ask my question
differently you have uncom uncomfortably
because you're taking you know finer
samples or for g infinity you know sort
of it's still
that is important because otherwise it's
not generic
so um well as i said uncountable is
really not the point if it's sort of
it's really infinite because
as we i mean there are sort of you can
approximate this by countably many and
there are sort of um
to be the most general your your
probability space has to be what's
called astronauts okay
so you should be in some way
for each for each vertex there should be
one sort of nearby it shouldn't have
just sort of better franchising around
um
because then you would start to be too
special okay so it turns out that
so behind that is some theory of
probability spaces which says that
actually
the most general probability space you
could think of
is essentially the interval zero one the
signals from distribution
so that's a theorem so you can think of
two probability spaces of being
isomorphic you have somewhere how you
met one to the other and it turns out
that you give me any probability space
and i can find the isomorphism which
maps it onto the interval 0 1
with the uniform distribution
question yes
but i think to be clear here
just substitute the natural numbers
so otherwise you will not have it to be
item free right i mean you said
something about sequences but then you
need n to the power of n or something
so i mean if you put the natural numbers
put some probability solution on you get
a special case
but you can't write
any probabilities by slack set okay
and somehow any probability space if you
look at it will give you something
exchangeable
so for the theorem to sort of be true
you need this kind of generation
if you want to approximate it you can
sort of approximate it by
any finite number
so
can you
help me understand the delta between
1a and 1b
oh so so the data is
so definitely is just
a one-dimensional sequence
which is invalid if you be labeled
so i could interpret a two-dimensional
sequence as a one-dimensional sequence
but then it's not invariant the way
the way we did that is not so so that is
true you could write this as
um
you see here i have a particular way of
doing that right i don't have the map pi
which so if you
if you had
a permutation of the edges
pi of i j is sort of and then it's
invariant
then you could see it as a
one-dimensional sequence because can map
and to n squared
um and then you would actually not get
this here okay so either hoover really
needs that you have sort of either the
same permutation here or one here and
another one here then you get a
different version of by this hoover
but you can't have a permutation of the
edges
that would actually give you
a difference
okay so in general they're sort of
our expert sits in the back
you can have sort of this
pretty arbitrary probability spaces you
have some symmetric operation on them
and if you have the symmetry operation
on it that will give you a
representation theorems which says that
your sequence can be generated by
choosing sort of some random variable
and then doing something else and it
sort of sometimes and and sometimes if
society group is
small it's not very useful if it's large
you get something as simple as in the
definition for sequences or in others
hoover for random race um and there are
many other version of sort of this kind
of
theory
it's a whole subfield and we have the
expert in the audience
yes um
uh
i'll maybe next slide
step further
uh next slide that's not a cece
yeah this one yes
so it seems to me that
even though
the
after assembling alpha after alpha 6
all edges are iig
after alpha is fixed and the feature of
all vertices
and but only once you condition on the
50s
so
first you choose a random w which is
choosing alpha
once you have this w
then for each vertex you choose a
feature and once you have fixed the
features
then
the edges are independent
all right
oh okay
for the alpha
the
like the function w of alpha x and y
can depend arbitrarily strange on alpha
yes
uh
is it possible to actually find such a
function
so
this is again a question of representing
it okay so
you can think of this as very um so
i actually like to think about it really
in the sense of a random graph which is
just a way to formulate that but you
again
okay so you have a function of two
variables of probability distribution of
functions of two variables which
actually can be characterized by a
function of three variables so in
principle you could write down the
function in some cases right
but in practice
um
in practice there are two things
one is that
we often actually don't need the alpha
so it turns out i don't think i have set
here did i put it here no i didn't
um so it turns out
that if your graph is such that if you
have the sub graphs on the induced
subgraphs on the disjoint vertex sets
are independent
which we actually have in many cases
then
the theorem says there exists a w and
not a random value
so then you don't need this sort of
coordinate
but w can still be quite complicated
okay because it's an arbitrary function
of two variables
um
in practice you might and actually if
you
put here the interval zero one
um
you sort of needs it
even though you might for instance say
wait a second my features should be
it should be gaussian vector in ten
dimensions or something like that i mean
you do machine learning you say that's a
relative distribution let's just say
it's a culture
and so it's a gaussian in 10 dimensions
and
then you say and in addition this
function should probably be smooth maybe
it's a scalar product of your two
features or the distance of the features
in something so when you do this
when you would model this in machine
learning would never allow this
complicated a function okay but you
would want to allow a more than one
dimensional space
and now if you take your
five-dimensional space
and you want to map it back to the
interval zero one
and make the two spaces isomorphic you
can imagine that maps which which have
sort of a nice continuous function in r5
and now you map them onto a function on
zero one that function will not be
continuous anymore okay so to some
extent if you really insist on the
interval 0 1 you have to allow very
general functions
in practice if you allow yourself more
reasonable feature spaces
you can assume that these functions are
maybe actually essentially linear
okay so it it turns out that okay that
has to do with something called the
spectral theorem you can expand any
function into sort of eigenvectors and
which is the same as w being finite
ranks in your approximation and being
the same as being fine at rank after
some other mappings just means that your
function will be a scalar product of two
of these guys so to some extent you can
in many cases approximate w by just
saying you have some probability
distribution on r r n or r k
and you take the scalar product of the
two and then you sort of have maybe sort
of to stretch some of the coordinates in
one direction the other so in practice
these functions are not as complicated
people never would use these complicated
functions they would say
i have my network i want to
non-parametrically
learn that i have some idea what the
dimension of the feature space is and
now i make my standard
analogs of better functions or something
for for higher dimensions as my space of
the graph font so
in practice people would not
and nobody would do this very general
setting and nobody would do the interval
zero one
but if you insist on the interval zero
one you better allow pretty complicated
functions here
okay so let me summarize the first part
a graph one is a symmetric two variable
function over a probability space
we can think of the elements of this as
features you map a pair of features into
a number between zero and one
and then once you have such a function
you can generate
the so-called inhomogeneous random graph
by choosing
first your features in your feature
space according to your probability
distribution one per vertex
independently
and then just independently as you
pointed out connect vertex i with vertex
j with probability w of x i x j
seems pretty natural right so
u and i are connected with some
probability which depends on his and my
feature
um and by aldous hoover
if you have an exchange family of random
graphs technically speaking you need
that you actually have an infinite graph
it's exchangeable and then these are the
finite induced
subgraphs then
you can always find some w
possibly random
which describes this thing
so this is
how much i would say about modeling
so i guess
just to have very basic questions um
exchangeable
is kind of like uh
isomorphic
if if everything was deterministic two
graphs are exchangeable if they're
isomorphic
well once this is exchangeable if
actually
if
any permutation is
so that
really makes the graph
very uninteresting very uninteresting
okay
complete graph empty graph i can't
i think someone says
right open triangle is already not
exchangeable if you saw deterministic
graphs are typically not exchanged
because it would really mean invariant
under all the latents
okay which deterministic sequence is
exchangeable it's a sequence zero zero
zero zero and the sequence one one one
and that's it
okay and which deterministic brass i
exchanged without
i think if you want to exchange it for
all n
it's probably either it's a complete
graph or the anti-graph peter is there
something else right
so
the question on this point what if we do
a surprise black model where the where
the blues are are all deterministically
linked for sure and the reds are
are not linked then it says that's a
graph that's a you know only if you then
say that i choose the color of a vertex
if you fix the color of the purchases
you have lost this exchangeability of
relabeling vertices and then it's not
exchanging
yes stochastic block models the way i
formulate it is an example
of an exchange build
so this is an exchangeable model
is that
equivalent to saying any two isomorphic
graphs have the same probability yes
by not only us no no no
it's the same as saying
two re-labeled graphs have the same
probabilities they don't need to be
isomorphic
well i guess those are the same things
it
okay
so
okay so what have we seen so far so this
we haven't seen yet but we have seen
that
graph fonts are pretty general model to
give
large random graphs
okay
so now we come to different notions of
similarity how i'm doing on time
this clock is not right okay
you also were talking about uh
like dense graphs so so far you haven't
said anything about needing graphs to be
dense
this is wrong okay so it turns out that
the way you wrote this thing
if the graph is not dense then w is
identically 0.
so this theoretically fits non-dense
graphs but the non-dense graphs of this
theory
okay so if you want to do
exchangeability for non-dense graphs you
really need
different notions you need different
symmetry groups you can have different
notions of exchangeability and we'll
need
different theorems to use and they do
exist in some cases in some other cases
we'll just say okay my underlying graph
may be exchangeable but the graph i see
is just the sparse subsample of that
which then will not be exchanging
okay so
let me review we have these different
notions of
similarities so now i should define that
for you okay
so let's start with subgraph counts okay
so we want to know when two large graphs
are similar
and we will
think of this at looking at your like
large graph from the left so i have this
huge large graph here in red
okay
and now i map a few number of vertices
oh i'm
this is not really working right for me
[Music]
so i take a few vertices three of them
and i look at some subgraphs this guy
and now i map these three vertices into
my large graph here here and here
and then i look
whether i see this subgraph
as an induced subgraph in the setting i
have done it okay so we map k vertices
into a large graph
we look what we see and then we count
how often we do see that okay so you
take some finite graph
you map its vertex set into your large
graph so v1 up to vkr is a large graph
one up to k is a small graph
okay so this is the image of the first
vertex in your small graph this is the
second of the small graph vertices this
is the last of the small graph vertices
is mapped into your large graph
okay you sum over all possible things
like that
then you look that if there's an edge in
your little graph whether you see the
edge in the large cross
and if there is no edge in the little
graph then you don't want to see it
right so adjacent matrix is one if
there's an edge so this means you don't
see it this means you see it
okay so this counts
with a little bit of tweaking
the number of
induced subgraphs and that could be
possibly this is a sum which contains v
to the k terms so i normalize
now it's not quite the number of induced
subgraphs because i allow
some of these vertices to be the same
if n is large
by the birthday paradox it's very
unlikely that if you map k vertices into
it randomly they are the same
so in practice the difference doesn't
really matter
this is just a different definition
slightly
and this is just more convenient for me
to do my proofs
okay you could do the other definition
everything works
just sort of the algebra gets more
complicated
so
if there's a that's what i'm saying if
you wanted this to be induced subgraphs
i would need them to be distinct
but i don't ask them to be distinct
so if v i and v j is the same
okay
then actually
um
we better make sure that we don't
map an edge to
so so then
it sort of
right so you so for example if i map
this if i map these two vertices to the
same
since my graph has no loops
this will not contribute here
but maybe i actually map these two so
this is my small graph and i map these
two the same well this has no loop and
there's no edge here so this is not the
same as restricting this to distinct
but if they're not distinct
you sort of
don't count these things if you would
map into a loop because my graph g has
no loops
okay
so um
and furthermore as n goes to infinity we
are really interested in large graphs it
doesn't really matter whether they're
distinct
okay
so now we call
a sequence of graph
subgraph convergent
yes
but you don't you're not asking h to be
a connected graph right so if
i don't ask it to be connected so that
means that you you could map two edges
to the same edge in the target graph
and that would that would count
do you want that
so i put that
so what you said i could do this
that's your map this to this
okay
yeah again it doesn't really matter for
a large end okay
and it's convenient because this form
actually
is right anymore it just turns out to be
convenient then it becomes sort of
easier to formulate carson's inflation
okay
all these differences really in practice
if i are interested in this limit n goes
to infinity
you just get x extra errors which are of
order k squared over n which
so
anyhow so but morally it's very simple
you have this large graph you look how
many triangles are in there how many
open triangles are in there and so on
and the sequence is considered subgraph
convergence if normalized by
k
so for triangles is three and so on so
normalized by what would you
so we call this
this frequency of h and g as an induced
subgraph and actually solves
on because of what we discussed
so that's one one notion okay
now
the notion of
think of this as a random thing is you
have a large graph g
and now you choose x1 up to xk
with the placement at random in your
large
vertex set v
and then you look
on the induced subgraph
which you see there or to be more
precise again
i define it like that okay so if if i
and g f x i and x j happen to be the
same
well i will only put an edge so
i will not put an edge there because
that would be a loop and my graph
doesn't have loops okay
so
um
it's still
a reasonable definition you could again
define this by saying i will look at the
properly induced subgraphs and you would
choose here injective maps
okay
and you would define sample k like that
okay
this one has an advantage
that if i sample
in a lot that i if i sample from a
vertex set if i sample the first five
vertex in the next five vertices
it really becomes independent
if you ask them to be distinct then
obvious doesn't become independent
anymore because once you have chosen
your first five one the next one have to
be different from that
and that is just convenient to have this
kind of independence in my samples
for the mass
so
okay so we call it sampling convergence
if the distribution of these guys
converge
now
why is this clearly equivalent to
subgroup counts
well what is the probability of seeing a
particular graph
well this is equal to
the number of possible samples
which is k to the n
in the denominator and upset is how
often this graph appears
so this is actually just in disguise the
same thing we had before
okay so the two of them are clearly the
same
and so we call these notions left
convergent because you think of it as
having
a large graph here i take a small graph
and map it into the large graph and see
if it's a you see that image or not
so
now let's come to computer science
okay so what's a cut
well
you take two subsets s and t in your
vertex set
and you look at the number of edges
which go from s to t
you may want to think of t as a
complement from s
you may think of t as the same as s and
it counts the number of edges inside the
graph as
um
in general you just have s and t and
look at the number of edges and you
divide by n squared okay
now a lot of things in computer science
can be just calculated from that for
example
max cut in a graph is just the maximum
overall s the number of edges between s
and s complement
mean by section you take the minimum but
it's a bisection so you ask s to have
size half and if n is odd you do here
minus one
um
okay
so
or you could sort of put here one third
there's sort of generalizations right so
now can we generalize that for more than
two groups is there some multi-way cuts
and
let me walk you through that slowly okay
so
now i want to look at k cuts so that was
sk
so now i choose actually
a map from your large vertice set into a
small set so now this will be notion of
testing the large graph from the right
so this is the same as just coloring
your large graph
don't worry whether it's a proper
coloring or not you just color it in
some way
okay which is the same
as
looking over all possible partitions
into k sets
and now you define
a weighted so now you say how many edges
are there from red to green you multiply
it by some constant j red green
you want to know how many arches are
there from green to blue you multiply it
by a different constant and so on right
so this really
sort of counts in a weighted way the
number of cuts between
all different pairs of different colors
given the partition or if you want given
the coloring
okay
and now
the generalization for mean by section
is i will fix
the size of these classes okay
since i again have to worry about or
even i put smaller equal one but think
of it as really fixing the size of the
color classes
and then you just take the minimum of
all possible
cutting into different groups of these
colors which have the prescribed size
and then you ask what minimizes this
constant here okay so mean by section
would just be that alpha is one half for
the two
and j is just one
and if you want mux bisection you make
um
you do just you make j negative
and so you can map essentially all these
global properties you might be
interested in in computer science
into this okay so this is the
generalization of cuts
and now we call it sequence
convergent
if all these multi-way cuts
converge okay so this would be my notion
of
cut convergence
now if you talk to statistical
physicists they will watch you in
amazement and say
what you're doing this is not cut this
is just
this is the energy of a spin model you
even call it j we also call it j this is
called the interaction matrix it tells
you if your spin is has a certain color
and the neighbors has another color what
the energy of cost of the two of them is
you sum over those this is just the
energy of your what we call spin
configuration you called colorings
and
this guy we also have a name for it's
called the microcanonical ground set
energy grounds that energy because you
take a minimum of the energy and micro
canonical first you fix how many in each
class you have
and once i realized they say
but you know entropy is important in
life and you shouldn't just define this
you should look at the free energy
okay so now i have to walk you so who
has seen free energies
not that many okay so the physicists try
to model these configurations of spins
okay and they want some statistics on
the spins think of the springs at little
magnets which can point up or down or
maybe you're in some crystal where they
can point up down right or left or maybe
think of them as weather at a certain
point in your crystal you're in this
configuration or in this configuration
or take a
simple model of a gas whether this site
is full or empty so that's what the
physicist thinks of this sigma
x
okay
and then they say well this
configuration of spins this is the
physics world had some energy
okay
and now things which have very high
energy should be unlikely it's very hard
to get something to high energy and they
weigh a configuration by what's called
the gibbs factor
by the energy e to the minus energy
and since i divided the energy in such a
way that it was of order unity
physicists will actually multiply it
back by n for reason we'll get to in a
moment
and then they want to calculate
probability distribution with respect to
this guy
and if you calculate probability
distribution with respect to this guy
then you have to normalize by this guy
which is for the partition function
okay now i can comment on why i put the
n here
this we normalized so it's of order one
here there q two k to the v so k to the
n many configuration
so this is exponential in n and if you
want sort of balance out
the different configurations
right so you could make this if this
scales much faster then you just would
choose the minimum energy and if it is
one much slower then you would just
could as well leave out this factor so
this is the only reasonable
normalization where you actually get to
balance what physicists call
the number of possibilities here and
energy
okay
in the previous slide you had this alpha
from delta k
is this come back
in the previous slide you have this
album yes
there's a fraction of the themes that
should be in one color class i see that
but in the previous line you had this
choice of alpha coming from
uh big delta sub k in the previous line
oh i have set here too the sum of the
alphas has to be one
okay because if you look at the sum of
the sizes of all color classes
has to be n right that's the number of
words so
so in other words if i fix a certain
color class to be n times alpha i
you better make sure that the sum of
alpha is equal one
because otherwise
this just giving the proportion of the
vertices in one color class right yes
so alpha is the proportion of vertices
in color in color cluster
and that's why it's called
microcontroller okay so physicists will
also look at this quantity where they
don't have the alpha
and then it's called the canonical
partition function
um
and it's different physics examples they
sort of describe different properties of
the world one is called free energy one
is called the entire these are sort of
all kinds of
but we are looking at
this particular version
okay because
it's sort of the generalization of these
cuts where i wanted to in particular do
mean by section for which i had to fix
the size of the classes
okay
and it's also something in the real
world right if i
yes i might model sort of having so many
atoms of oxygen and so many atoms of
hydrogen in this room
and i might put some probability
distribution but in practice
if this room is closed
okay that's just a certain number of one
kind of a certain number of the other
kind so in many sort of when you try to
do the isolated physics experiment in
little body but in this border you have
a fixed number of the different
particles and that's where this comes
okay
and so this is sort of what the
physicists are interested in that
quantity because
it's sort of mixes between entropy how
many coloring you had if you don't even
count this as a proper colorings or not
and energy which sort of punishes
certain configurations and makes others
more likely
and so
we just say okay if these converge
then we call this thing
our convergent again
okay
so i gave you all these different
notions
and it turns out
that they're all equivalent okay so this
is actually the main result of this
theory of graph convergence it takes
roughly 100 pages to prove
and there is a notion of a cut metric i
will define in a moment
the first 50 pages proves that the cut
metric is equivalent to this one
and the second paper proves that it's
also equivalent to these two and it's
sort of complicated in the details
okay
but in from very far away it's actually
not that difficult so
let's for example look at these
multiverse cuts okay
they're defined in terms of how many
edges go from red to green
well if well i haven't defined the cut
metric okay
so the cut metric will be defined in
such a way that naturally if two graphs
are near in the cut matrix the cuts will
be similar
that's why it's named it okay and some
of the others are more complicated and i
will prove some of them and i will not
prove the others
so
so now i have to define for you what the
cut metric is so you understand the
theorem so before the cut metric what
you have is just they're all equivalent
okay so
if all of these converge for all finite
subgraphs
is the same as the sampling converge
that we already discussed
it's the same as if for all case a
weighted multi-way cuts converge
it's the same as if for all k
the micro canonical free energies
converge
so
um so what is the cut metric i mentioned
okay so now we want to look again when
do we want to compare we want to compare
two large graphs okay and we want to say
when they are similar and we don't want
all these these constraints from the
people who tell us what they want about
the graph really want some more
intuitive thing some distance between
graphs right so for example you might
just say all right take the two
adjacency matrix subtract them from each
other take some norm and that's a metric
okay and that will actually not be that
far from what we're going to do okay so
you want something that sort of much
more hands-on than this infinite
sequence of things you have to look at
okay
so
now we want to compare graphs on
different number of nodes so i can't
really subtract the two adjacent
symmetrics okay that's an issue
so what do i do for that
well
let me just first do it in pictures we
have some graph here
i call that the phd student graph
this is sort of
my phd students and this is their thesis
okay and the first phd student really
only has to read his own
he has the first picture he only has to
read his own thesis okay now comes this
poor second guy i said you know what you
should read so and so it's phd thesis
because we're going to build on it and
obviously you have to read your own
and the third student has to read three
seasons the last student unfortunately
has to read all these other phd thesis
okay it's called the half graph and now
what do i do
i take the number of one two three four
five six seven
fourteen
points
and i take my unit interval and divide
it into little intervals of width one
over fourteen
and now i put a black square if there's
an edge
and a white square if there's no edge
okay and if instead having this sort of
seven by seven it would be 14 by 14 you
would just get smaller squares
but if you squint your eyes they will i
mean these steps will look slightly
different but the two of them will look
pretty similar okay so this cl seems to
be some way of saying i compare graphs
on different nodes or vertices if these
pictures look similar
okay so
formally
i take n i replace it by a dist a union
of disjoint intervals of length one over
n these little
things
i look at the squares
which is sort of one of the interval
times one of the other intervals this is
one of the square one times
nine
and
then i set this function equal to one
if this guy had a one in the adjacency
matrix and to zero otherwise okay so
this is just the pictorial
representation of the adjacency matrix
in a way that i can compare graphs on
different number of nodes in this case
diagonal is going
here
okay so this is a function
so this is sort of funny right for
matrices we draw them like that
but for function we have x and y and we
draw them like that so i have no idea
why we decided to draw weight is this
sort of right and down and functions up
and right so
it's a different convention
black is one and white is
okay
and now
so
how would we compare them where we do
what's called the cut network
okay
so what is this
so we could just do we could just take
this function take the absolute value
integrate from zero integrate over the
whole square that would be one way but
it turns out that this will be a two
fine way we will ask sort of
there will be graphs which are similar
in many purposes which we will then call
far away because this one norm is
actually not the right norm so what you
do instead is the following
you look at subset s and t of the unit
interval so imagine that this w is again
your checkerboard right
so if the w is a checkerboard
then your little square on the little
square either have a one or zero okay
so and maybe now this w was a difference
of two of these guys but still either on
this square this thing is
negative or it's positive okay and if
it's positive and this maximum will
either be obtained this is being equal
to this or equal to minuses let's say
it's obtained so this being equal to
plus this
if it's obtained for this equal to plus
set then on this little square if
there's a one i might as well include
the whole one
whole square because that only makes
this bigger
and if it's equal to zero i can as well
leave out the whole square because
otherwise i can make it smaller
or put differently i will get to that in
a moment okay so if this w was actually
one of these step functions
then this s and t would actually
correspond to original subsets of your
graphs and the union of a corresponding
intervals
so then this would look like that okay
this would be s and here t is s
complement
and this would count the number of edges
between here and here
and since this w the width of the
interval the squares are five minutes
are one over n squared
this would be normalized okay
um
so we define it like that
and
then um
we have so so that's some distance okay
you can you can convince yourself that
if you have two graphs it will be only
zero if the graphs are exactly the same
isomorphic
so the problem is that you will have
non-isomorphic graphs
so you could have isomorphic graphs
where the distance is non-zero
right
that's an issue that's a problem so what
do we do
so we want to just take the minimum over
the labelings
so what's the labeling of a continuous
interval
it's so-called measure preserving
transformation
what's the measure of preserving
transformation
it's a transformation which if you start
with a random variable this is uniform
the image is again uniform
okay
so which is the analog of permutations
if i have a uniform point in a finite
set and i do a permutation then again
i'm uniform okay so the measure
preserving transformations is exactly
the analog of the labelings
and so we take the info over the
labelings
and so in particular if you're
underlying w's they're actually
representations of step functions for
graphs
then
these the labeling shuffling around sort
of little intervals
don't change the distribution it's still
the uniform distribution and so this
info contains in particular relabeling
so if two graphs are isomorphic this
distance will be zero
and
um
so now we just define this distance like
that
okay and if you write it out
you take the infamous measure preserving
transformation you take the maximums
over sets s and t
and you you compare the cut in one graph
to the cut in the other where the cut is
defined with this continuous function so
that you compare graphs on different
vertices
so
if you didn't put this integral here and
put the obsolete value inside which
obviously is a bound that would be the
l1 but we don't do that we do this
because it's very natural because it
compares it says sort of that these two
graphs are similar if embedded into this
set of functions because they have
similar cuts
yes
so w g one you are missing this file
right
let's see
because we are taking the interval over
labeling
of fine
[Laughter]
should fight
so you have a step function wg
and then you apply the measure
transformation that you which i wrote up
here or you put right here i cannot
and i think i'm running out of time
let's see this is a nice
okay so let me just talk about that from
the distance and next time we will do
details
so how will we now prove this theorem
so we prove so assume that this cut
distance is some epsilon
okay
well let's sort of start with these
multiverse cuts the multiverse cuts are
just essentially k square possible cuts
so you will believe me that if this
distance is epsilon then maybe these
cuts can't be much farther away than k
squared times epsilon
it's not quite true you need some
rounding errors and you have to do
integer rounding and stuff to make that
precise but roughly it's true okay
and these well this actually holds for
the cuts before you take any minimum so
whether you put it in exponent and some
over something so these two
sort of it's sort of clear that there
will be sort of some
k square times epsilon something like
that
what about these guys
well that we will i will show to you
okay it's not that easy but it's
actually turns out to be true as well
okay so
here you again have a constant which
depends on k
but otherwise
if the cuts are this if there is the two
graphs are way epsilon in this
then actually these final graph
subgrounds are away epsilon times it
turns out k squared
okay so this one direction which is easy
and the other is much more complicated
and i will give you the proof
for both direction in this example in
some detail
next time and then we'll discuss
how to this how to construct limits and
what is sort of
to be proven
thank you
you've got a lot of questions
maybe it will break here and then if you
have questions